Jordan this is exciting what are we
about to do we're about to go on the
hunt for Tuscan truffles the very rare
fungus that only grows at certain times
of the year anything we need to know
about hunting for truffles
Koza they'll be almost a parody to theme
and providing for toothy much you sonico
de kado [ __ ] sapere prima no no we don't
need to know anything before that to
cure we need to know anything Thanks so
you're sure these dogs serve remember
cross they do something nice they go
this way what is that is that a truffle
that's a truffle right yeah okay stars
just found it truffle okay hey wait
what's this you found another one yeah
look at this they just found another one
just get in here
I strongly suspect these guys because
they knew we were coming hidden these
because they're finding them very easily
don't you think so
I concur they keep going
you get down like you're a truffle pig
do you mind oh ain't going truffle you
did it good job Mikey that's as
legitimate as anything these guys have
been doing I'm sorry we've been scammed
what I'd like to do is go very deep into
the woods and once we are very very deep
in the woods a boy I would like Louise
Walla to kill my friend can't you tell
him that I might wish to use rabbits to
find those truffles why is that we care
if I use a rabbit does the rabbit
doesn't have the nose for it
Oh being subjugated in this country I
think I'm losing my mind
it's very cold and very dark I don't
know these guys and I'm with Jordan ed
and they said I was okay for me to kill
Jordan
these dogs are finding truffles that
have been hidden clearly minutes before
we got here
this whole thing's a goddamn scanner he
works harder than he does Louise always
in the corner like this Oh a companion
at work who does nothing you know who I
am the truffle hunter I do I work at the
late-night show you I probably do
nothing you stand off to the side yet
you get to share in the truffles that I
have dug in the earth with my hands we
came hunting for truffles instead we
found a nugget of truth
you